how big of a deal is it like being a kid
and then the the macklemore album comes
out in 2012 and he had always been
independently successful in like a name
like in the underground you know but
things really changed uh when that album
came out i mean it changed everything
for the whole city and like nothing will
be the same after that and i also feel
like we got to a point where like we
stopped respecting macklemore for some
reason when he's like legitimately like
the nicest dude ever has the best morals
is probably one of the most transparent
artists of all time
quality [ __ ] music thank you brother
he was dealt uh a shitty like internet
hand in the sense of like he had a crazy
haircut beat kendrick for the grammy you
know what i'm saying i really think
that's all it was it was it was
literally just him beating kendrick for
the grammy
everyone's allowed to be corny bro or
everyone's allowed to be seen as corny
to everyone like you're like but that's
you can't knock someone for that but
when they take an award that you felt
like should have went to the one of the
greatest hip-hop albums of all time how
are you not gonna become like an enemy
in people's but that didn't stop bro
like i ain't gonna lie like after that
whole [ __ ] happened he took me on tour
and like he like helped put me on you
know what i'm saying and like he's the
best he's and bro like he
has he he consistently does [ __ ] for the
city that he doesn't even like talk
about and yeah it's one of them things
where it's like people always got an
opinion and i get it because i and but i
ain't gonna lie it's been very telling
like to like
i watch people who like don't [ __ ] with
him but [ __ ] with me but don't [ __ ] with
him for the same reasons that like they
[ __ ] like yo i'm just you feel me i'll
just do something
i'll be walking around seattle and like
the people i'm around will say something
about mac and i'm like okay okay let me
get these hits off y'all ain't gonna
[ __ ] with me in like two years yeah you
feel me because i just be knowing bro
it's like [ __ ] always have [ __ ]
to say but it is what it is bro like
everyone's allowed to have an opinion
and [ __ ] but like
i just think like mclemore for whatever
reason like
you know i really think it was the
kendrick moment
but i think like we just forget like how
good the music was he hasn't put out
music in a couple years but yeah it
still is very good so i don't want to
eat it bro like he and he's like an
independent anomaly like thrift shop you
know diamond song and it's an
independent an independent diamond song
like people don't have a different kind
him and ryan lewis are so stupidly you
know what i'm saying bro like and they
brought so much to the game when it
comes to just their visuals there will
never be another artist like chance or
like macklemore or like cause these are
independent anomalies and i'm gonna be
honest bro like when people say like
independent and they're really not
independent mclemore wasn't that and the
reason and some people don't know bro
they don't know he literally just hired
of labels radio staff to work his
records like he wasn't signed because he
had warner brother working all his [ __ ]
to radio but he wasn't signed to warner
brothers he literally just hired yeah i
already know bro and he's just been
solid from jump from me bro like any
time that he's like what you got going
on i'm like oh i'm talking about things
like send me the contract or something
he's the best when you got it bro let me
see it you send me like you know what i
mean and he does that for people i think
he also broke down so many walls for
like you know
just transparency and rap like you know
the fact like he talked about his drug
addiction so openly and yeah and it'd be
pissing me off too because i feel like
he came from like this hip-hop
background like he was a boy he was on
some backpacks he was on some backpack
[ __ ] but then when he blew up all the
backpack fans were like
you're not this anymore it's like bro
like really listen because there are
those songs you just don't like it's
famous now that [ __ ] that should be
getting to me bro that [ __ ] happens
every time white backpack heads anytime
someone it's all love i'm a white
backpack head i'm just saying i know
those white backpack fans are weirdos or
weird bro but this i we're we're both
those guys so we can't hate on them you
know quite a bit yeah